[موسيقى]
هذه الطائره انتجتها شركه لوكيد مارتن
الامريكيه كجزء من مشروع سري لتصنيع
طائرات يصعب رصدها على شاشات الرادار
في صناعه الطائرات افضل لاحقا الى انتاج
المقاتلات الشبح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تم تصنيع اثنتين وثلاثين طائره منها لصالح
سلاح الجو الامريكي وكذلك وكاله ناسا
الفضائيه ولم تصدر هذه الطائره لاي جهه
خارج الولايات المتحده نظرا لحساسيه
التكنولوجيا التي تتمتع بها هذه الطائره
بلغت سرعتها النحو 4000 كيلو متر في
الساعه اي كانت حينها اسرع من اي صاروخ
ارض جو كما بلغ معدل ارتفاعها نحو 26 الف
متر ما جعلها بعيده عن تهديد المقاتلات
والصواريخ
[موسيقى]
زود الطائرات البلاك بيرد بافضل ما توفر
حينها من منظومات التنصت الالكتروني وكذلك
منظومات الرادار لكشف التحركات الجويه في
محيطها وايضا تم تزويدها بكاميرات لمراقبه
الاهداف البعيده
[موسيقى]